[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler free
review of Ant-Man and the lost
quantumania I will be having a spoiler
review coming out on Thursday so stay
tuned for that so for this film I was
super super excited because this is the
film we're first getting our new big bad
and Kang and it is played by the great
Jonathan Majors shout out to when I was
reviewing Lovecraft country where he
first came on the scene I did say this
guy was gonna be something special so
turns out he is and he's getting this
huge part and he delivers his different
level and he is the best best part of
this movie and not only the best part of
this movie best part of the MCU
performance wise in years like amazing
having said that this movie has a lot of
problems with it and I was worried going
in the sense that you know you always
look at the writer you look at the
director and with the director being
Peyton Reed again who did the first two
Ant-Man films that made me a little
worried because I liked Ant-Man but
Ant-Man the WASP I did not like I
thought that was one of the worst Marvel
films like did not have much to say good
about that film that worried me and then
having this writer who also wrote on
Rick and Morty they seem to want to have
a lot of Rick and Morty writers writing
on different things for Marvel that have
to do with time travel and all the weird
stuff going on that it's in right now
and the reason I bring that up is
because the humor they elect to do in
this is very Rick and Morty now if
you're a Rick and Morty fan great you
know that might cheer you up I'm not a
Rick and Morty humor fan type of person
so there's like a certain character
you'll meet that's very very like
straight out of Rick and Morty show
um I did not think really worked here so
I wasn't crazy about the humor and I did
not think the humor in general was
consistent especially for a Marvel film
not saying that there wasn't humor there
was attempts at humor but you know the
hard laughs the laughter people are all
vocally laughing in the theater were few
and far between for this film and this
film though that wasn't my main issue
the main issue I had with this movie was
the pacing and it's weird because it
starts off really engaging and gripping
and I was really into it and something
just happens or you get towards like you
know I would say about halfway through
the film that you feel like you're numb
and I think for me what I think was
causing this is that because it's in the
quantum realm this film it feels too
stuck in one setting where you start
like subconsciously getting tired of it
and you want a visual change because it
doesn't really like Branch out a lot in
the quantum realm you still feel like
you're of like these three set pieces
that you're in the whole movie and it
just kind of gets stuck you know and
doesn't go anywhere at a point and I'm
annoyed because I thought this would be
the film where you have this great
villain and great performance that you
would know it's the top of phase five
that would kick off with some big bang
and he'd get to put his foot down that's
not really the case here I didn't leave
the film thinking like I'm really
excited before it's next there's big
ramifications no like it felt safe it
felt like it could have been something
more and unique for Marvel and it still
falls into a lot of Marvel things you've
seen before and goes a very very safe
route which was extremely disappointing
for me I think that the side characters
were not great uh the new characters one
of them played by William Jackson Harper
just not given a good part here a very
small part and not great and there's
another character you're gonna meet who
is very one note and you've seen his
character 100 times before that is just
out for revenge and nothing much else to
it now saying a lot of issues with it
I'm gonna get to good stuff in a second
but another thing that was annoying me
about Kang is that the way you learn
about him you don't learn much and it
really doesn't give you enough of a
motivation for this particular moment
why he's doing what he's doing which can
be annoying especially for someone who's
not like watched everything like
evolving the Marvel universe so that
felt flat to me as well now having said
that Michelle Pfeiffer really brings it
here is amazing but I actually thought
after Jonathan Majors which I was really
just blown away by the performance
actually of Catherine Newton who was
cast as Cassie Scott Lang's daughter I
thought she was great and she brought a
certain charm and levity to the part of
Cassie and was exciting and felt right
in the MC like it she was really just a
standout for me too in this film so that
was a very big highlight I actually
really liked what they do with Modoc
um but that's coming from someone who's
not like this big Modoc fan to begin
with so I think a lot of people are
passionate about the character you'll
see a lot of people saying you know that
they didn't like how they handled it
with him I thought it was fine I mean I
enjoyed the character and I thought he
actually had the most funny parts in it
and there's a little twist with him
which I like and I think when I look
back at this film there's one scene that
is amazing in it and I think that scene
is worth the price of admission alone if
you're a big Jonathan Majors fan or a
big Kang fan it's with him and it's when
he first meets Ant-Man that is all you
need to know and that scene was
incredible and I wish we got more of
that scene in this film and it kind of
gives you that best moment in the middle
somewhere and then it kind of just
tapers off and gets you know silly goofy
but it's not the way you would want to
be silly go if your words are working
like a Guardians of the Galaxy it feels
like maybe if this was in someone else's
hands this would have done way better
it's almost too real I liked it and then
the more I thought about it I liked it
less and I wish that it was just more
planned out and not so reliant on past
projects future projects but not even
that I'm getting a little like the
Multiverse stuff's nauseating at this
point I I'm I'm annoyed that Marvel has
decided to keep going with the different
timelines and all the stuff that we
learned in Loki that they're going with
this still because I feel like with all
the phase four films like Doctor
Strange's movie and this time travel
going on like I'm I'm getting over the
time travel now because the problem is
you get attached to character and that's
not the same form or you see a villain
it's a different form and you're like
well who is that what am I supposed to
feel for that character can we just have
a world where I care about what's
happening in that world where there's so
many different versions and timelines
it's too much and I get why they were
doing it to do things differently but
it's still going I'm already sick of it
I'm like man we still got a long way to
go with these different universes so I
think that's going to turn off a lot of
people who aren't like Marvel die hards
especially in this film like okay this
is just getting like almost ridiculous
now and two just all over the place with
that it's not hooking me and it's so
hard because to rate it on a number
score I want to give it a 7.8 because
it's still was enjoyable it's not a bad
film and it has its moments but it
really is brought up again by Jonathan
majors and Catherine Newton for me I
think they were so enjoyable and their
characters are great that I would you
know say it's worth it to see for that
and of course for Michelle Pfeiffer who
really gets to shine as Janda here where
she really gets to do much in the
previous two films so this like she
really is excellent in it and I just
think that that makes it fun to watch
but you have to lower your expectations
and it's not this big kickoff that it
should have been for phase five you want
to start phase five with a bang get
people who are already doubting Marvel
now after a weaker phase four back in it
and this to me doesn't do it and that's
disappointing enough but it's it's not
bad so I wouldn't give it a lower score
like I still enjoyed it I'm just
pointing out things that keep it from
being that next level we know marvel can
get to or being a really good film and
it's just so much points up because
again how good the villain is with
Jonathan Major's performance and
Catherine Newton to me as Cassie was
great so that brings it up but what
brings it down from being like a nine is
all the issues I have with the pacing
and not having a flow in this film and
it just feeling stuck in this one
setting I know it's supposed to be in
Quantum realm but I wish I'd branched
the quantum realm out more because they
oh it really feels like you're just
stuck in three different places that
just go back and forth with just weird
editing so oh and I'll mention too I'm
not gonna say any names I don't say this
instead of jealousy but people who get
like some people get to go to like the
early early Premiere you know they know
these shills they're sending out there
that will say like amazing or the
post-credits scenes are incredible the
post-credits scenes two of them are fine
nothing got me excited though and it's
it's no
don't listen to that they're fine giving
this one 7.8 let me know what you
thought stay tuned for my spoiler review
and I could kind of break down more
things I thought about different
characters and what they did and all
stuff like that and please follow me on
Steve Riley show on Twitter Instagram
and Tick Tock for more of me and I'll
see you next time